lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
practicar la resta de números de varias
cifras como ejemplo tenemos mil menos
528 veremos varios métodos para hacer
esto cómo podemos usarlos juntos y por
qué funcionan para visualizar lo que
significa esta diferencia voy a dibujar
algo que tiene una longitud de mil
unidades y a esto le vamos a quitar 528
unidades la diferencia será nuestro
resultado vamos a resolver esto de dos
formas usaremos una tabla con los
valores posicionales y también usaremos
lo que se conoce como método tradicional
que es la forma en la que muchas
personas aprenden a restar este tipo de
cantidades especialmente si tenemos que
reagrupar vamos a hacer ambos
simultáneamente dibujemos nuestra tabla
de valores posicionales tenemos la
columna de los millares lo escribimos y
señalamos los números que están en esta
posición luego tenemos la columna de las
centenas aquí no tenemos centenas y aquí
tenemos cinco centenas luego tenemos la
posición de las decenas aquí tenemos
cero decenas y acá dos decenas y
finalmente tenemos la columna de las
unidades aquí tengo cero unidades y aquí
tengo ocho unidades ahora vamos a
reescribir estos números pero usando el
método tradicional
tengo un millar cero centenas cero
decenas y cero unidades
a esto le vamos a restar cinco centenas
dos decenas y ocho unidades terminamos
nuestra tabla y vamos a resolver ambos
métodos al mismo tiempo comencemos con
lo que tenemos
comenzamos con mil unidades en la tabla
lo representamos como un millar a esto
le queremos restar cinco centenas dos
decenas y ocho unidades como lo hacemos
si ahorita no tenemos centenas ni
tenemos decenas ni tenemos unidades con
el método tradicional tenemos el mismo
problema si vemos la posición de las
unidades tenemos cero unidades a las que
queremos restarle ocho unidades vemos
las decenas y pasa lo mismo la solución
para esto es reagrupar vamos a
descomponer este millar para poder
llenar estas otras posiciones un ejemplo
es como cuando cambiamos un billete de
cierto valor por otros
y monedas de menor valor cuantas
centenas tiene un millar tiene diez
centenas así que descomponemos este
millar en diez centenas 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 y 10
aquí quito este millar y ahora tengo 10
en la posición de las centenas esto es
útil porque ahora puedo restar centenas
a estas 10 centenas que tengo aquí puedo
quitar estas 5 centenas de estas 10
centenas pero seguimos teniendo el mismo
problema de las decenas y las unidades
lo que podemos hacer es descomponer una
de las centenas y transformarla en 10
decenas vamos a hacerlo tenemos esta
centena y la descomponemos en 10 decenas
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10 y aquí si le
quitamos una centena a estas 10 centenas
nos van a quedar 9 centenas ahora
tenemos 10 decenas aquí ya solucionamos
el problema de las decenas pero sigo sin
unidades acá pues hacemos lo mismo
quitamos una decena de aquí y la
descomponemos en 10 unidades
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10 unidades hago lo
mismo de este lado quito una de mis
decenas y ahora tengo 10 unidades ahora
si ya estoy lista para hacer la resta 10
menos 8 es igual a 2 como representamos
esto aquí vamos a quitar 8 de estas
unidades 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y 8 nos quedan
dos unidades ahora veamos las decenas
tenemos 9 decenas y vamos a restarle dos
decenas nos quedan siete decenas como lo
representamos aquí nos quedan nueve
decenas y vamos a quitarle las dos que
nos piden restar y nos quedan siete
decenas nos quedan dos unidades y siete
decenas que es lo mismo que tenemos por
acá lo importante aquí no es encontrar
la respuesta sino comprender cómo la
obtenemos en las centenas tenemos nueve
centenas y le vamos a quitar cinco
centenas lo que nos da cuatro centenas
aplicamos la misma idea acá tenemos
nueve centenas y quitamos uno dos tres
y 5 nos quedan 4 centenas este 4 y este
otro 4 son lo mismo esta es la idea
general y aunque a veces con el método
tradicional parece que hacemos magia
cuando reagrupamos cantidades realmente
lo que hacemos es tomar este millar y
descomponerlo en 10 centenas que ponemos
en la posición que les corresponde luego
tomamos una de esas centenas y la
descomponemos en 10 decenas que ponemos
en la posición de las decenas finalmente
tomamos una de esas decenas y la
descomponemos en 10 unidades y ahora si
podemos hacer la resta con esto
terminamos